Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is a mind-boggling new piece of work
from scientists at Google Brain on how to
hack and reprogram neural networks to make
them perform any task we want.
A neural network is given by a prescribed
number of layers, neurons within these layers
and weights, or in other words, the list of
conditions under which these neurons will
fire.
By choosing the weights appropriately, we
can make the neural network perform a large
variety of tasks, for instance, to tell us
what an input image depicts, or predict new
camera viewpoints when looking at a virtual
scene.
So this means that by changing the weights
of a neural network, we can reprogram it to
perform something completely different, for
instance, solve a captcha for us.
That is a really cool feature.
This work reveals a new kind of vulnerability
by performing this kind of reprogramming of
neural networks in an adversarial manner,
forcing them to perform tasks that they were
originally not intended to do.
It can perform new tasks that it has never
done before, and these tasks are chosen by
the adversary.
So how do adversarial attacks work in general?
What does this mean?
Let's have a look at a classifier.
These neural networks are trained on a given,
already existing dataset.
This means that they look at a lot of images
of buses, and from these, they learn the most
important features that are common across
buses.
Then, when we give them a new, previously
unseen image of a bus, they will now be able
to identify whether we are seeing a bus or
an ostrich.
A good example of an adversarial attack is
when we present such a classifier with not
an image of a bus, but a bus plus some carefully
crafted noise that is barely perceptible,
that forces the neural network to misclassify
it as an ostrich.
And in this new work, we are not only interested
in forcing the neural network to make a mistake,
but we want it to make exactly the kind of
mistake we want!
That sounds awesome, but also, quite nebulous,
so let's have a look at an example.
Here, we are trying to reprogram an image
classifier to count the number of squares
in our images.
Step number one, we create a mapping between
the classifier's original labels to our desired
labels.
Initially, this network was made to identify
animals like sharks, hens, and ostriches.
Now, we seek to get this network to count
the number of squares in our images, so we
make an appropriate mapping between their
domain and our domain.
And then, we present the neural network with
our images, these images are basically noise
and blocks, where the goal is to create these
in a way that they coerce the neurons within
the neural network to perform our desired
task.
The neural network then says tiger shark and
ostrich, which when mapped to our domain,
means 4 and 10 squares respectively, which
is exactly the answer we were looking for.
Now as you see, the attack is not subtle at
all, but it doesn't need to be.
Quoting the paper: "The attack does not need
to be imperceptible to humans, or even subtle,
in order to be considered a success.
Potential consequences of adversarial reprogramming
include theft of computational resources from
public facing services, and repurposing of
AI-driven assistants into spies or spam bots.".
As you see, it is of paramount importance
that we talk about AI safety within this series
and my quest is to make sure that everyone
is vigilant that now, tools like this exist.
Thank you so much for coming along on this
journey, and if you're enjoying it, make sure
to subscribe and hit the bell icon to never
miss a future episode, some of which will
be on followup papers on this super interesting
topic.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!